hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to resident evil
village
i noticed something this goat eye be
glowing
and i don't know what that means also is
that yellow up there can i get up there
i don't know if all these like i'm so
used to seeing yellow and being like oh
that's something and i don't know if
that's something but that sure looks
like something
i just don't know what the sum is maybe
there's a way to get over there and then
eventually climb up because this is
gate and i could get to it from the
other side but why is this goat
shield glowing bang
well that was a wasted bullet sorry
ma'am oh wait a minute
what the hell
i got a trigger okay there's my freaky
baby
and my freaky wife okay uh white mineral
found in this region could probably sell
it
to whom or i could gift it to
someone anybody really
could be anybody i don't know someone
someone who would definitely adore it
and appreciate it for its power
the power really we offer these goats of
warding to people
to protect the village and its people
any who break them shall feel mother
miranda's wrath
god i want to break them i really want
to break them they look like a bobble
head
[Laughter]
that was probably a mistake i don't care
though
whatever hey wow cool all right
wow stick the family photo in there find
a way to open the cap
the castle gate you say the castle gate
you say
wow castle
really now really okay this is open
hello peekaboo i say
is anybody here
wait a minute what's
what's this what's this power i feel
resonating from this picture
very strange also who are you are you
mother miranda okay maidencrest okay
that goes in the the thing the thing
with the thing
the thing on the thing that opens the
thing you know that thing
should disaster fall upon the village
seek out the crests
one is in the care of the church the
other is at louise's house
who the hell is louisa why the hell is
louisa
okay so am i in the church i think i'm
in the yeah here x here
okay so i got to go to louise's house i
think that might be
behind the gate that it was locked
before but i'm not sure
oh oh i could have saved
man i'm a fool i thought that didn't you
know auto save but
i might have just lost all my data if i
hadn't kept going
what are you doing what are you doing up
there you come back here you [ __ ]
poink okay cool all right so look out
for the shiny this is where my adhd is
really going to come in handy
oh yeah no i'm bored
oh not bored get dead yeah
i know there's probably a reward for
completing all those that's very special
and very important and i will play it
when i do my completionist playthrough
after i'm done with this one
but i don't have nearly the patience or
the attention span to be able to get all
those now
also i think louise's house was this way
for frick for frack all right
louisa is that you
oh louisa
luisa
ah okay all right okay all right louise
all right louise all right louisiana
all right okay all right i'm recording
right just checking yeah i'm recording
okay
just make it sure i can't tell i'm on a
laptop so
it's all on one screen so i just i have
to
flower
man don't you love games teaching people
lessons
i learned i knew it i knew it i see
flower i get afraid
every time i go to make chicken and
dumplings out i'm going to just get a
surge of adrenaline because i'm going to
be so scared
mine yeah mine give me that
oh sweet dude oh sick dude
okay uh
well i don't want to put it here else
when i run away i'm gonna step on it but
also
it sure do seem like maybe it might be
the best idea
i've ever had mother miranda
louisa you're here miranda
louisa can i get up there no i can't
even jump
oh that's block i thought this was
oh this makes a lot more sense oh my
hand really messed up
well i can always reattach it apparently
wait they're different colors
are my hands different color is this
wait i can't remember in the other game
did they just give me a completely
different hand because remember like
mia cut it off and then it got
reattached
i never really questioned that does that
mean does that mean ethan is kind of
infected
as well that might be what that means
i have no idea anyway let's get out here
ah yeah i only need two fingers for that
one
all right come here you bastards i know
how to block now
that's fine i see you just get stabbed
oh get stabbed come at you come at me
come at us come i do decree you must
approach
aka you must come oh i hopped
hello who is grumbling you know you're
gonna get a you're gonna get a face full
of stab if you keep that up
i think i need to reload this not that
i'm gonna use that the shotgun seems
like a very potent weapon and i'm not
into using my potent weapons ever i like
to conserve those so that i never
actually waste anything
can i get over this oh i can't hop over
this i could have over the other thing
but not this
i see you scrap
who's snuffling can i
thank you who's snuffling
oh my god i'm trying to block all right
well
you know you get ready because you're
gonna get you're going to get blocked
you get blocked dude yeah
get some yeah you think i can't kill you
with a knife i can
i'm probably going to have to okay all
right
is there a way to dodge i think there's
a way to dodge isn't there
i can't remember i thought in the other
game there was like a way to dodge
oh man too bad you're oh yeah get
stabbed
get blocked oh yeah this guy good thing
he doesn't pull out his machete that
would really be an advantage for him
unfortunately for him my arms are super
sturdy
it's all the fungus coursing through my
veins can you
just oh he did okay thank you it's like
oh sorry i was inconveniencing you let
me clump over
all right cool i hear another
snuffleupagus
scrap this will be super useful hey
hey oh he's got a weapon i do too bang
buying a bomb of buying a home can't
wait till i find the shopkeeper
spend all this money on pillaging off
these corpses
can i block with a gun i can okay hey
bud
oh looks like crystals
that's dope as hell is there vodka in it
all right goodbye later dude all right
it says it
it says i can craft ammo but honestly i
know the stabby works so
and and if the is there a way to dodge
is it let me hang out on the way
controls here no no no controls
i'm using a keyboard i'm using a
a keyboard quick turn run
guard i don't see no block
okay probably not all right whatever
don't matter i'm gonna need it
i'm too good for it anyway oh you're
gonna get stabbed
in the okay you i was stealth mode how
dare you
hey stop oh i can duck under you
oh my god oh wait no that's bad this is
bad duck
all right you know what i had it okay
up to here with you please tell me that
actually got you
oh my god are you really serious with me
right now
you really serious i chung along with
you with a
full-on shotgun blows so i can kind of
ring around the rosio all right chem
fluid that's good
you dirt bag
craft me up this uh i want to save my
gunpowder because i'm
insane and i don't actually like using
the things that they give me
uh-oh close the door hi hello
you should maybe you should have locked
it hey what are you doing here
what the frick are you doing in your own
home what do you think you're doing
please don't hurt us whoa
it's okay i'm not gonna hurt you i'm
just glad to see normal people at last
have you seen the other survivors no
they're all in louise's house and she's
not answering in the gate is locked
quiet girl he's an outsider
oh
[ __ ] we're setting ducks in here can
your old man walk
no one of the monsters cut him
he's lost a lot of blood we have to get
into louisiana
quiet you're not very good at surviving
stay here be quiet don't move until i
get those gates open
yeah yeah again maybe lock the door
that might be a good idea lock
you all right you need a knife to plug
up that wound
oh yellow
hey you left bullets in your backyard i
hope you know about that
what is that it's gunpowder in case you
weren't
in case that wasn't clear all right is
this a reloadie
blah boom a rusty old gun
all right let's find something here
i'm here and snuffle up a guy which is
the plural of snuffleupa
gus maybe not hello
if it's just the one of you i shall stab
thee if it's two
i am going to run away
you can never survive is that a fire
who's on fire
who's who's fire okay you know what gun
time
oh i'm running i'm running where's more
flower oh please give me flour oh
i didn't think there were so many of you
okay watch this you want to see
something sick watch this
watch this watch this sickness is my
name
come come come here come hither oh you
guys have been flowered have you that is
unfortunate for you
oh hello okay wait a minute hold on
wait wait hold on wait no wait stop wait
no
wait stop hold on wait hold on
oh shoot i blowed him
am i supposed to be able to shoot all
these guys because i'm about to run out
of bullets
what's up dude what's up dude
whoa grit on the head
put it on your head oh yeah get get some
get a lot of
you know get a lot hey don't don't
yeah you you're gonna pay for that one
in dividends okay
i bloasted one of them did they drop
anything of value
well money has value depending on what
you ask otherwise it might just be rocks
okay so i something tells me i'm
probably not supposed to try to kill all
these dudes but
if there's more flour i'm i'm gonna
throw so much flour in your eyes
you [ __ ] don't even know what's
coming because you'll be blind
right i could you know okay hang on i
gotta
hold on i gotta get more bullets
oh 15. oh it makes that makes a lot more
than i thought it did
well that's good for me and bad for you
[ __ ]
get ready for some gun
if i had flour i would flour you up
my beer batter whoa i was not reloaded
dimitrovsky will be so impressed with me
when i regale her with that tale
she'll be blown away
okay so what the hell was i doing i was
supposed to open some kind of a gate or
something
i think they're supposed to like i don't
know open a door
the thumbnail a phone call eventually
i'd be able to chop through it but
apparently not
okay hey uh boom
hang on papa hey don't worry
uh let's do something quick well you're
doing a whole lot of nothing
slow so you know you can't really say
anything
bill what oh up here uh oh well good
thing i killed all those dudes because
otherwise they would have absolutely
murdered you both
but i'm a hero this is a secret bathroom
why is there chem fluid in the bathroom
you poop better
do they wipe their butt with chem fluid
whatever uh kaboom oh sorry
that's locked well louise is that you it
seems like you actually know how to lock
things hello
what are you oh there's a crest in there
okay so i need something to unlock that
maybe i could unlock this
yeah no good thing i killed all those
dudes i really do think those two might
have been
dead come on it's clear
for the doors god damn it
hey look my fingers are blit off
you're welcome
he's not used to relying on other people
i'm sorry
yeah you get far in life like that we'll
be safe in here
won't we see if we're here then out
there that's for sure
you could have clambered over i guess do
you know anything about what's going on
here
it doesn't make any sense mother miranda
has always protected us
nobody said sir
father
someone's kind of a wine oh yeah uh i'll
be the door
keeper oh thank you yes no i'll get it
yeah you just oh yeah all you got to do
is sit and
moan look i'm doing all the work here
if you want to sit in the house excuse
me yeah there's so much blood
oh god i get it i get it oh yeah
okay so there's got to be a way to get
in or something
oh hello anybody
you didn't knock good enough old man
louisa open up it's me elena oh
oh maybe step out of the way of the gun
shouting you'll draw the monsters calm
down who's this
a friend stay back father
for god's sake julian let us in no
they'll smell the blood you'll endanger
us all
my father will die out here that's not
my problem what's going on
these people want to let a dying man
into our home come now these
people are our friends go on go inside
come this way the period will track the
bears i'm not from this village i can't
let you in
no i'm ethan you lean go make yourself
useful and check the grounds
i said go you're
hurt well
if elena trusts you and so do i
come inside ethan thank you thank you
very much
louisa your home is lovely i'll check on
the others
last time i was invited into someone's
home it only went well
anyway clickety clackety click clack
clack okay cool just wanted to type out
my life story real quick
no don't mind if i look at all your
things do you all right here i go
um ah very interesting
oh fascinating i wonder if this is all
the
places where there's like secret stuff
this way
which way who's talking
who's talking to me somebody talking to
me
all right sure whatever it might be
actually where all the secrets are
because one of those statues and and the
other thing was where like
a spooky secret was louisa they broke in
again got more of the livestock i don't
think we'll make it through winter at
this rate
ernest is still missing too we can't
find him anywhere has mother miranda
abandoned
us well maybe you shouldn't paul your
faith in mother miranda maybe you should
put your faith in
someone taller someone more uh
robust powerful powerful is really the
word that we're all
thinking of
hi come inside the others are waiting
hello hey what's up gang
ethan in the house you're gonna get us
all killed guys anton
he helped leonardo and elena we were
doing fine by ourselves
yeah you look it take a seat oh i don't
like this
last time i took a seat is this all
that's left well man
your entire village left
all that's left there is no one left
a worthless invalid
a stupid whaling [ __ ]
and you you drag a bloody man and an
outsider in here like it's nothing and
expect to be all
safe there is no safe
every sorry bastard out there has been
ripped in half
but tomorrow
tomorrow we'll all be dead
just like a damn husband put a socket in
roxanna that's enough
this house has protected my family
and drunk or not you are all welcome
and safe in here whatever
dude you want to go outside you can tell
me what the hell is going on here
we don't know one day we were a quiet
devout village and the next the monsters
came
and attacked us and they
they kept coming wait louise where is
your husband
did they no no he he is out there
somewhere he he went to get help
yes yes that's that's it he he went to
fetch help
uh okay sounds really convincing let us
pray yeah
for him let us all of us good
come oh great mother miranda
may your blessings reign like milk from
the heavens
great ones hear our voice
together as one in reverence
as the midnight moon rises on black
wings
so we make our sacrifice
mother miranda now
the tea should be ready you guys come
help me that was a spell just to get the
tea going
prayer i've heard it before there was an
old woman near the graveyard
[Laughter]
[ __ ] as crazy as a bag of rats there is
wisdom
in her devotion though and i hope it
protected her
as it shall protect us sure okay
hey dude what's up my man stay back
no let me go
hmm
have a gun i ha i have a gun
i have a gun i got a gun bang boom
[Applause]
that voice sounded familiar
oh no that's elena i thought i said
no sounds very much like the voice actor
for uh
claire i'm so sorry father hey
hey that wasn't your father anymore you
did the right thing
uh-huh oh well uh you didn't do enough
of the right thing
elena elena no there's nothing you can
do
okay well that's fine this entire place
is collapsing
yeah well we'll be safe in here you
couldn't save him
he was already gone leave me alone
no we're getting out of here together
you and me
best bestie we're besties now come on
we're good friends all right fine then
juice
you gotta get out of here yeah i gotta
get out of here yeah you know i gotta go
everything's on fire but how about that
cup of tea you know really uh really
feel like waiting around for that
anywho uh scanning
for information secrets nothing
okay well uh you think your papa's
cooked yeah all right sorry about you
okay all right well i'm leaving
and you can stay if you want i guess
you're the one that did the shooting so
is that a pot of stew oh hell yeah
okay hello whoa thanks for the money
take the screwdriver out of the key ring
if you need it
is that a code what is that supposed to
mean
what shotgun where oh there okay
that's handy man i do not have a lot of
ammo they are really being stingy about
it
which i think is good keeps it keeps it
well balanced
very uh tight hello
okay a lot of drawers oh
truck key examine
items in more detail you might find some
clues okay
examine a screwdriver
is that what that said out of the key
ring
that's what that meant okay squew duivoo
all right good good good hey what's up i
got this truck key
damn the fire's moving fast yeah
uh don't worry you just stay there
i got it don't worry we could just get
through this wall
yeah if we could just how could we
just uh these aren't screws there's no
way
it's impossible i can't what the hell do
i do am i stupid
the answer is no but also you guys
probably
got a wrong answer because you're stupid
and said yes so
really who's this stupid one might be
you
that's probably me ma joke trick it was
not
truckee i
i was using it on the truck i thought
the truck was so old and stupid that
there was no way
step back we can bust out with this
i didn't think there was any way in hell
this thing was working
uh-huh this is gonna work yeah oh yeah
yeah watch out yeah
the whole building won't collapse from
this definitely
why didn't i go backwards why would i
ram through the brick wasn't there like
wood behind me
oh hello uh
well that
nathan are you all right um fine
let me back up again i don't know there
wasn't any time
uh oh i guess we'd give up then
oh handy yeah i didn't think it was
gonna work anyway
i thought it was a terrible idea grab
one hurry
let's move come on bestie we got this
let's go
and try not to breathe in the smoke i
know
thank you ethan you're kind
yeah i am kind and smart too family is
safe
i do too once you get out of here maybe
you'll get to meet them
yeah well you want to meet my freaky
baby uh oh i shouldn't have said
something like that because that
guarantees death
is coming for elena
there that's our way out
it's a window you heard of it it's glass
we can break it fight them there's too
many okay
killed like six we don't talk like that
we'll find a safe house to put you in
until i can find my daughter
my hunch is she's in that old castle no
why is that my place is full of nothing
but blood and death
and i don't want to be alone while
you're father
uh gun time elena no that's not him
not anymore he said my name
father yeah elena bat yep here's the
guaranteed death
jumpers oh no stay there
come on give me your hands
ethan go save your daughter
don't give up reach for me
well that seemed unnecessarily dramatic
if only you were nine feet
tall could have reached me
well honestly like i get that that one
was very tragic but there was
everything she could have done to
prevent her doom
it was literally legitimately everything
she could have done to prevent that
and also she it's not a very far fall i
i feel like she would be screaming in
agony from the fire burning so
anyway don't get it yeah it's probably
fine
tom seems fishy about that if only she
knew about what a window was
if only she understood
this place is going mad has it
[ __ ] is this happening again oh my
freaking hand
good god i smacked my wound hand
[Applause]
helene elena or should i say
claire claire
yeah oh i know what i could do here
bam i know i should feel like more
remorseful but
to be perfectly honest that was so that
was
that was a bit ridiculous
i'm sorry it was very not ridiculous
unridiculized
[Applause]
oh hey what's up hey you mother miranda
i've heard so much about you
i drank your tea hey all right later
i guess what was that hey mother miranda
mother m all right fine be that way
all right well that was interesting
um a really like lovely adventure
it's my fault for saying the magic words
that gets people killed
uh hi oh hey old bag of rats
yes death has visited them all
[Laughter]
uh okay i guess the joke's over
well time to hit the old dusty trail
i got myself some circles
see demon crest oh yeah well that ain't
right
these you could always trust resident
evil for the most
incredible puzzles the most
outrageously difficult puzzles
all right man that was a toughie
i was a real toughy gang that was real
tough nothing but blood and death
huh nothing but blood and death
what's going on here go freaking cold is
what's going on here what is this
what am i looking at here apparently i'm
just i'm a badass
that wasn't cold at all i'm fine
apparently all right whatever gang
whatevs uh oh i can't crouch
just taking a little soak cleaning
myself off
i want to be respectable and presentable
for uh when i get in this castle hey wow
what's up hey what's going on
hey how you doing hey knock knock
hey knock knock knock
anybody home whoa what the hell
oh god i didn't mean to get that hey
what's up
oh didn't think anyone was left
you must be pretty tough huh
who the [ __ ] are you oh
you're not local even better
oh ouchies wait wait a minute hey what
the
you hell don't love you
all right magneto what the hell is wrong
with you what the hell is wrong with me
i'm ethan by the way you're whining
we're almost there
oh i'm sorry the metal spike in my chest
is a little
wine inducing
just having a good old time the man is
of no real use to anyone else
and my daughters do so love entertaining
forms
furthermore i can assure you that you
entrust the mortal house
my daughters and i shall deliver to them
the [ __ ] up what where
you mean you'll screw around with them
in private more is the fun of that
give them to me and i'll put on a show
that everybody can enjoy
oh so gauche what do we care for bread
and circuses
the man thinks suffering is assured yeah
cause a man's dick is cut off in the
castle blah blah
i've heard all your arguments hello some
of you were less persuasive
than others but i've made my decision
heisenberg the man's fate is in yours
no mother miranda i must i must protest
but a child and his devotion to you is
questionable
give the mortal to me i will ensure he
is ready
and don't be a sore loser you'll find
your food somewhere else
quiet now child adults are
talking i'm the child you're the one
who's arguing with miranda's decision
she wouldn't know responsibility if it
was wealthy oh
keep glory one day your head might
actually take your ego
and gentlemen we thank you for waiting
and now let the games begin
[Applause]
let's see
hey you know my name get ready
oh okay
nine eight
seven
okay thank you guys hey let's all have a
good time out there have a good game
everybody all right let's go
yeah what's up there yeah run for your
life
i will pretty good okay this way oh
oh bam [ __ ] all right
blood out very nice thanks
i'm used to this i run for my life like
a lot oh hey
dude hi how are you
ow well that's my brain
yeah another one here's round two where
am i what happened
oh sweet
well that was fun you're still alive
impressed i thought you were gonna blow
oh
wow this is just cruel
oh i see i see the way i see the way i
see the way haha i see the way dudes
get wrecked bam kaboom
crouch i'm a genius oh i'm not jesus how
do you do all of this my word
you truly are as strong as they say who
is they
oh you don't think i've let you get away
break break it i'm presidential
uh you forgot about this look whoa
something like fresh american ground
beef
do those freaks have rows yeah why would
they have rose
why aren't they bros hey thanks for the
money and the ammo do i have my gun
how what you didn't even take my gun you
amatoise
you am a twirls you amateurs
oh well all right well boring
well they can't see me anymore do they
not have cameras here probably not
they only got an extremely intricate
system of spinning blades why would they
have cameras
anyway hey what's up gang
how you doing good to see you all again
uh listen uh heisenberg you had a good
shot at there
you didn't get me you didn't get me you
were kind of crap at that
but uh you know i think it's lady
demitrescu's turn had uh
showing me the business you know what i
mean showing me all the business so
just oh hey what's up
all right not much hey how you doing
okay good talk there like secrets back
here or something
i feel like there'd be something back
here hey okay
just blood and death i always promised
this so i guess i shouldn't be too
surprised
but all right
oh i've been waiting
hi how do you know my name anyone who is
anyone has heard of the likes of you
a hero searching for his daughter
though i must say that castle arouses
suspicion
yeah and so do you
i am but a humble merchant here
oh forgive my manners call me the duke
now to business weapons ammunition
healing salves anything you desire
i can provide i can provide
okay yeah uh-huh um
yeah you wish to make a purchase well
when you put it like that special today
spend a day live till tomorrow oh yeah
gunsmithy the duke's purse
everything what sell items
i got a crystal i got two crystal skulls
oh hell yeah
am i supposed to sell these or is there
some other reason
i'll just sell them i'll probably find
more or i'll never find more odd times
ethan
what was i supposed to keep those when
we have him
what do you mean bloody bling what is
this
shock oh recipe for shock and ammo
sniper rifle animal recipe for minds
that's good
uh extra baggage okay emotional or
otherwise great
oh that's only two hundy wait why is
this free
why is this free
what why is this free
i see anything else
why was that free i mean i'm totally
down with it but
why was that free yes i can see why
you'd be interested in that
mr everywhere weapon charm what oh i
have some kind of like
i have some kind of you know i don't
really want that but
i don't really want these things they're
kind of silly but whatever
it's all good why is this only
i mean it's left by albert wesker okay
you know what i'll do it are you eyeing
that one
yeah you know well because i got nice
eyes
uh okay cool i that's
neat um wait okay so i can sell this
other gun now right uh
i can sell the lemmy because i have this
and it's
it's kind of the same as a little more
damage
also it's upgradable but it's got
upgrades on it i'm gonna i'm gonna sell
this
because it's worth a lot why not right
okay sell this okay trade i suppose
you'd call this
a farewell to arms okay well you
shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut up pay me no mind
i won't pay you no mind i'll pay you in
my mind uh whatever yeah i don't need
that
okay this is all an investment ethan
it is oh whoop
two three okay look forward to seeing
the fruits of your exploration
cool sounds good man all right i got a
dope ass gun
okay hey hi are you tired horse i just
want to sit are you uh
is it just you is it just you horsey for
this whole wagon um seems like a lot of
stuff in the wagon
you okay you need some water
you all right all right well i guess
you're good anyway
hey how you doing ah good good to
finally uh
approach oh great knockers on this
yeah a lot of effort big doors big doors
big doors big door powerful doors castle
dimitriscu
could rose be here rose
i do not like this painting i do not
like that painting
do not like it um stab
sorry sorry guys
sorry money
all right
you don't mind me just uh wandering
hey
you guys got a typewriter in here
somewhere
oh i'm so sorry
i'm so sorry
miss dimatrisk
yeah i'm sure that was nothing i'm sure
that was nothing
mask the angels blinded gays what
looking for rose oh baby
[Laughter]
oh i'm just gonna let you do that
apparently man
blood yeah man blood i got a lot of it
i'm pretty much 100 man how
why why am i just cool with this how
many
horrific stab wounds have i sustained
hey what's up hey mother
i bring you fresh prey you are so kind
to me daughters
hey what's up hi yeah now
let's take a look at him ah just look at
me wow
well ethan winters yeah you escaped
my little brother's idiot games did you
oh yeah that's your brother
let's see how special you are so special
yes yes mother
hey what's up ow that's my wound hand
okay a little gross very gross listen
this is not a sexual thing it's about
power right i just want to
be very clear starting to go a little
stand then let's devour his man flesh
quickly mother i am the one who captured
him
now now daughters first i must inform
mother miranda
but later well there will be enough
for everyone you like mushrooms
pretty much mostly fungus
now the shoe's on the other foot
but you don't train the neck muscles to
actually look up for you very much so
i'm happy to be able to provide the
exercise
what are you doing later hey see you
around
okay oh bye-bye
was that mine what was that
cool hey this is awesome i am
happy well this is the end of the game
for me
thank you all so much for joining uh i
hope you guys have a wonderful day
uh really glad i was able to have this
full experience here um but you know
like i gotta say worth the money worth
the money this game
but you know great ending though i
really liked it ethan really got his
just desserts there
and now uh he will reside for the rest
of his life in castle dimitriscu which
was always the goal
uh so thank you everybody so much uh
look i look forward to resident evil 9
when it comes out
the high expectations for this one very
tall expectations
very heightened expectations for the
next installment of this great game
series so thank you let me know what you
thought down in the comments below and
as always
i will see you in the next video
[Music]
bye-bye
you